in the opening scene we are introduced
to Two Brothers Joe who is retired from
the Army and Danny who is still serving
they are currently on a hunting trip in
the desert amidst their activity the two
talk about their third brother Roy Danny
wishes that he joins them as well but
Joe thinks otherwise he believes that
Roy is a troublemaker as he often goes
to jail it is revealed that Roy traded
his career in the military for MMA but
he got injured in a match and now he
drives a truck the scene then cuts to
Roy who arrives at a fight location it
turns out that he can't let go of his
MMA dreams so he still fights an
underground tournaments at present Troy
is already late for the fight but
despite this he takes a moment to engage
intimately with his girlfriend Lisa
showcasing his carefree and easy going
nature in contrast to his brothers a
short while later the fight commences
and being a former MMA fighter Roy
dominates his opponent knocking him out
he then arrogantly returns to Lisa for a
celebratory kiss unfortunately this
distraction allows the opponent to
recover and land forceful blows on Roy
turning those tables around the defeat
causes a huge loss of a client named
Julian for whom Roy fights here it is
revealed that Roy has been fighting for
him for four years and has earned lots
of money for him however Julian who is
also a ruthless Mafia leader claims that
his recent performances have declined
significantly he assumes that his focus
is diverted because of his girlfriend
and as a result Julian executes Lisa
right in front of him whoa later that
night Julian takes Roy to one of his
warehouses where he stores tons of rare
diamonds after retrieving them from
mining lands Julian assigns Roy with a
job to transport those diamonds securely
from Vegas to Baja offering a
substantial sum of one million dollars
as payment if he succeeds Roy is taken
aback by the offer and wonders why
Julian chose him over his armed goons in
response Julian provides him with three
reasons firstly he is a professional
seasoned truck driver with a great
driving record secondly roya's two
brothers in the military which can be a
plus point for him and thirdly he owes
him furthermore Julian threatens that if
Roy refuses he'll kill his brother as as
well as Joe's wife and daughters with no
other choice Roy hesitantly dials Joe's
number but the latter who is still upset
with him doesn't even pick it up the
following day Dany takes a break from
his work and visits Joe's residence upon
arrival he finds his brother engaged in
farm work tending to livestock when
Danny brings up the topic of Roy Joe
tells him that he called him the
previous night but he didn't pick it up
Danny asks for the reason to which Joe
expresses his frustration towards him
Joe cites a pattern where Roy only gets
in touch when he needs something from
them assuming the same motive this time
joke's on you bro I don't need anything
your wife's just gonna die cause I
screwed up their conversation is
abruptly disrupted by Roy's arrival
however instead of offering a warm
welcome Joe treats him harshly causing
Roy to regret his visit as he is about
to leave then he intervenes to console
Roy the two brothers then talk in
private and Roy extends an invitation
for a long ride to Baja Danny agreese
considering that they can spend some
time together after a long Gap in the
next scene the Journey Begins with the
two brothers hitting the road after a
long and tiring Drive Roy pulls over to
an underground fighting arena that is
operated by his friend there they watch
a fierce fight between two fighters
named big Duke and Barney boy owing to
his formidable strength big Duke swiftly
gains victory over Barney is just a
bitch-ass dinosaur following this the
event host asks if there is anyone in
the audience who has the guts to
challenge big Duke and Roy steps forward
disregarding his brother's advice the
fight ensues and Roy eventually defeats
the opponent using a Chokehold technique
the next morning the brothers continue
their trip aboard the truck several
hours later they reach the diamond
Warehouse where they are scheduled to
retrieve the diamond-filled container at
the location they meet Julian's trusted
associate named Paulie who shows the
crates to them he further explains that
the diamonds are cleverly hidden inside
the drink bottles so that the cops won't
find them easily after this they load
the container worth 50 million dollars
on the truck and depart for Baja as they
drive Roy notices the low fuel signal on
the truck and so he pulls over at a
nearby gas station amid the refueling
process they also enter the adjacent
convenience store to buy some food and
drinks a few min Slater a group of
masked armed gangsters show up outside
the store and start robbing Royce truck
one of the gang members manipulates the
truck's wiring to start the engine
without keys while the others buy him
time by unleashing gunfire tragically
killing the store owner in the process
the robbers then make off with the
stolen truck in an attempt to thwart the
thieves Roy fires shots at them but his
efforts prove fruitless Danny is unable
to understand what just happened and who
they were however Roy doesn't have time
to explain so he asks his brother to get
into the store owner's car before going
for the chase they soon catch up to the
robbers but when the bad guys opened
fire the brothers are forced to stop the
pursuit at this point an enraged Danny
presses for an explanation on what's
going on he also wants to know what's
inside the container left with no
options Roy finally discloses that the
truck contains rare and uncut diamonds
worth 50 million dollars that belonged
to a merciless Mafia Kingpin is that all
Roy not long after the news of the
failed delivery reaches Julian enraging
him he begins to suspect that Roy has
deceived fled with the diamonds later
that evening the police officers led by
detective David Johnson arrive at the
crime scene and begin their
investigation they find Roy's truck
abandoned in the middle of the road but
get no valuable leads the following
morning the masked gangsters returned
back to the same Diamond Warehouse turns
out that they are none other than
Paulie's man and he deliberately
dispatched them for the diamond Heist it
was his clever move to steal the
diamonds from Julian by Framing Roy and
his brother for the same elsewhere Roy
and Danny are now left out in the desert
they're forced to head back to the town
on foot because the car they still got
damaged due to the numerous gunshots as
they walk Danny claims that their big
brother was right about Roy as his life
is full of troubles he regrets
accompanying him to this journey and
vows not to join him on any other trip
in the future in the next scene we see
Joe who arrives back home from the
grocery store only to discover that his
house is in the state of complete
disarray he rushes inside frantically
searching for his wife and daughters but
they are nowhere to be found it appears
that Julian has abducted them as a
consequence of Roy's actions after a
considerable walk Roy and Danny
eventually reach a location where they
acquire a phone signal Danny observes
several missed calls from his brother
and Returns the call as soon as Joe
picks up he informs about the kidnapping
he appears to be completely unaware
about what is going on in response Royce
speaks up saying he knows who has done
this Joe becomes enraged hearing his
voice and even threatens to kill Roy if
anything happens to his family following
this Roy contacts Julian and puts it on
speaker before talking to him he tells
him about the robbing incident and
assures him that he will bring the
diamonds back Julian provides him with
48 Hours of time to find the diamonds or
else he will kill Joe's wife and
daughters hearing this Danny and Joe are
very disappointed that he risked the
family's life for the sake of his
illegal business however they have no
time to fight each other because
something bigger is at stake right now
hence the Three Brothers decide to work
together and go for their family's
rescue as Danny and Roy wait for Joe to
arrive at their location The Duo are
spotted by detective Johnson and his
colleague from a vantage point atop a
hill despite this they choose not to
apprehend the brothers due to a lack of
concrete evidence instead the detectives
decide to monitor their activities
closely meanwhile Joe goes to a secret
underground bunker where he's stored a
lot of weapons he gathers some rifles
and ammunition before heading towards
his brother's location after a few hours
on the road he comes across his brothers
and the first thing he does after
stepping out of the Jeep is punch Roy in
the face following this the trio heads
towards Julian's Mansion but unbeknownst
to them they are tailed by two
detectives they arrive at the mansion in
the morning and being a former Soldier
leads his brothers inside they use their
military tactics to take out all the
guards outside the Mansion one after
another Joe and Roy then enter the
Mansion while Danny takes a sniper
position to cover his brothers from
outside in the midst of this Paulie also
arrives and walks straight inside
Julian's room where the mafia leader is
enjoying some private time with two
girls Julian angrily chastises Paulie
for disrupting his personal time but the
latter seems to be there for some other
reason with a Sinister smile he shoots
the two girls before admitting that he
was the one who robbed the diamonds
Paulie further asserts that the diamond
business is actually owned by his family
and Julian is just an adopted son of his
uncle thus Paulie is now here to take
over the business from him the
conversation is soon interrupted when
they hear gunshots outside taking
advantage of this distraction Julian
knocks Polly out seconds later Joe and
Roy storm into the room and hold Julian
at gunpoint however the brothers can't
kill him right away because they still
don't know of what their family's
whereabouts this gives Julian enough
time to knock Joe out he then proceeds
to confront Roy when suddenly Paulie
gets up grab a pistol and shoots both
Joe and Julian he then orders his men to
load Roy to the vehicle in order to take
him to his base Julian dies on the spot
but Joe manages to survive because of
his plot armor shortly after Dany having
lost contact with his brothers rushes
into the Mansion but Roy is already
abducted by then together the two
brothers track down Roy's phone location
and head for the rescue on Route Danny
contacts his batchmate Jimmy asking him
to accompany them with the necessary
weapons at the base Roy is surrounded by
Paulie's armed guards who are also
holding Joe's wife and daughter's
captive Paulie devises a brutal test Roy
must fight one of his strongest guards
with the promise of releasing Roy's
family if he wins accepting the
challenge Roy steps into the arena to
fight Paulie's formidable enforcer
however he is already tired from going
through a lot and as a result he
struggles to match up with his
opponent's strength on the other hand
Joe Dany and Jimmy reach the confines of
Paulie's base Jimmy positions himself at
a distance and takes out the guards one
by one meanwhile Joe and Dany progress
forward shooting guards on their way in
a parallel scene Roy gathers all of his
remaining strength and ultimately kills
his opponent using an MMA move at this
point Paulie also hears his guards being
shot so he decides to make an escape
however his efforts are futile as the
brothers eventually Corner him Joe is on
the verge of shooting him dead but the
detectives along with the police force
arrived just in time and stopped Joe
from committing an unlawful act never
mind the other 30 guys they killed the
commotion ends is Joe's wife and
daughters are released from captivity
afterwards detective Johnson extends his
gratitude to the Three Brothers for
helping him in apprehending the mafia
members whom the FBI have been pursuing
for years they don't even care that the
brothers just killed 30 people in the
final scene The Three Brothers reunite
reconciling their differences and
Bridging the gaps between their
relationship Roy finally gives up
underground fighting and instead starts
helping Joe in his farm if he gets that
old itch he could always just fight a
cow subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching